oh hello there oh don't mind me I'm just
walking in the jungle or am i that's
right I mean space or Emma that's right
I'm in the jungle again I can tell that
you have a tough mind this video is not
for the weak-minded this video is going
to make you think how can our eyes be
real if you don't have any nice today
we're going to go through the reddit
where all the toughest thinkers go to
Socrates Plateau if they were still
alive this is where they would spend
their time spreading their wisdom I'm
talking of course about I'm 14 this is
deep ready it's your mind ready to be
blown let's begin coincidence or not if
ABCDE okay equals 1 2 3 4 5 ok then 11
plus 14 knowledge equals 96 percent but
hard work equals 98% both are important
but fall just short of 100% but attitude
equals 100
now that's that really makes you think
coincidence or not we will never know
but at least we've learned and but six
that's hundred and ten percent actually
it's a hundred and eleven moving on this
hit me hard Instagram that's right
this is why I don't have an Instagram
cuz I'm a Christian channel thank you
very much
all these sheeps these sheeps these
fools so easily persuaded by the devil
obviously tumblr getting to real guys
okay it's a light bulb and a mousetrap
this has deeper meaning the light bulb
represents an idea of an individual the
mousetrap represents how quickly society
is to destroy that idea are you [ __ ]
[ __ ] no it's just a light bulb
falling on a mousetrap shut the [ __ ] up
okay I don't know what the meaning is
but if it isn't what the person said
you're kind of proving it right she sent
her idea and I read judgment just like
she says the same
I don't like that one either intelligent
people will understand that's right
having this massive weight of brain
amount having this hugely
disproportionate brain just look at all
these happy people but I'm too smart to
be happy I've watched one too many
episodes I've reckon Marty and then I
knew it was done then I knew depression
was real my next one parallel lines have
a lot in common but they never meet ever
you might think that's sad but every
other pair of lines meets once and then
drift apart forever which is pretty sad
too nothing hits me harder than parallel
lines I never thought about lines before
this is deep I don't know what's going
on but I'm crying on just a thought of
[ __ ] thinking they look like Danny
did I'd be so happy if I saw Danny
DeVito when I look into the mirror then
I would truly be happy why am I wearing
headphones if there is no audio
that's an iPhone Mac Xbox Playstation 3
Wii internet pocket-money
more than most families budget not happy
at all
use a rock as a camera the happiest kid
in the world I wish I had a rock some
kids are so like I wish I had hands some
kids were so look I wish I had kids
Heather so look oh my god it keeps going
this is so sad
whoo next time I see a boob I will look
at a book ten times to compensate 20
times for every boob I see I will look
at 200 books one single poop if they
titanic sank in 2017 everyone would be
taking picture the [ __ ] am I supposed to
do save the ship but at least if we all
work together we could do it hashtag
save Titanic 2017 recipes I'm fine
save me if only one person would open
their eyes this person could be saved
notice how her her her toe is like
perfectly aligned with the knee that's
kind of trippy it looks like she's
growing nails out of her knee that's
disgusting when you clean out a vacuum
cleaner sorry when you clean out a
vacuum cleaner you become a vacuum
cleaner have you ever thought about that
I bet you haven't thought about that one
mm-hmm a psychologist came to my class
and was talking to us then he asked a
question he said tell me would you
rather get shot or get heartbroken no
one was answering so I did and I said
shot and he asked the why I said because
getting shot can be healed
he looked at me and said who agrees with
her no one answer then he said that none
of you have had your heart broken
they don't know the pain it's like
getting shot with a 50 Cal straining
nuts that's how it feels and even that
can heal you can heal you can grow back
your nuts but you can't grow back a
heart Christian Jim people think it's
fun and cool to be whoa mol it's
actually pretty shitty
and frustrating being conscious in an
unconscious society basically society
you hear me I'm about I'm here looking
down on you and I think well those those
people look pretty dumb it's so hard
being this well you don't understand the
suffering of my intellect yes this is my
man Neil what is he saying
almost all armed conflict in the history
of the world came about because opposing
science believe different things to be
true oh my god are you telling me are
you telling me that people have
different ideas and opinions no Neil
that is too far even my open mind I
refuse to accept this effect Neil go
back to your science and stay away from
deep thinkers like me
I'm gonna destroy you dead just remember
next time you take my iPhone or iPad you
take away my happiness
hahaha pity PI's basically shitposting
with his career at this point what makes
you think that's right when this video
ends your happiness will also disappear
but don't worry there is another video
waiting for you grab a plate and throw
it on the floor ah did it break yes
now say sorry to it sorry did it go back
to how it was before now do you
understand it's your birthday Matt tío
said I didn't respond are you not
excited to be 15 he asked reading my
book I ordered I turned 15 long ago
because my mind down here down here I
might be 50 maybe more like 12 but up
here I am a man of old age with many
wisdoms and an awesome and may hint a
collection would you like to see come
come my child come come buy that we're
gonna end this episode live it like if
your mind had been open just a little
bit if you learned something today leave
to likes if you ever read a book leave 3
likes if you watch 5 Rick and Morty
episodes in total leave for likes if
Jaden Smith is your wallpaper leave 5
likes that's impossible
you can't believe 5 likes now excuse me
while I go into some deeper thought oh
hello there oh don't mind me I'm just
walking in the jungle or am i that's
right